So we have this chicken and the egg
problem and those of you, I'm assuming,
most of you are familiar,
this is actually referred
to as k-means clustering.
It solves the chicken and the egg
problem by smashing them together,
which could be a pretty nasty picture,
but essentially,
it's just an iterative algorithm.
What you do is, just as it is says here.
And we'll take an illustration in a
minute, you randomly, yes just randomly,
pick some cluster centers.
You might try to be a little smart
about how you do that or, or not.
I find it easier to be not smart.
And then, once you have the centers,
we know which points should be
assigned to those clusters.
Once we've assigned to the clusters,
that's step two,
given the points in clusters, step
three, we can re-assign the center, and
you set that, you set the new
cluster center to be that.
And step four is, well if any
of the cluster centers move, and
the only reason they would have moved
is because you changed the assignments,
you go back to step two.
And this is classical k-means and
I assume most of you have seen that.
But, just showing a few
in the contest of,
context of segmentation here's a nice
little example from Andrew Moore,
recently appointed the Dean
at Carnegie Melon.
Congratulations Andrew.
So here we have k-means, right?
So we've got a bunch of points.
Now we know where we think
the cluster should be, but
that's because we're smart.
A computer's not so smart.
We picked some random centers,
so there they are.
Not a particularly good
choice of initial collection.
We then partitioned the space up, right?
So those of you from computer
science recognize this diagram.
This is the, the fracturing of the,
of the space such that this line says
that everything here is closest to
that point, more than any other point.
And so once we have those assignments,
what we can do is,
we move the centers to be at the center
of the points that were assigned to
that cluster, and then we iterate.
All right?
And we repeat that until it terminates.